Liam Payne opens up about becoming a  first-time father it's been fantastic  eetzi was with the 24 year old singer  backstage during z100 new york's i heart  radio Jingle Ball at Madison Square  Garden on Friday where he shared how  becoming a dad to his eight month old  son bear has changed him oh yeah I mean  in every single way my tips have been  given so far which are very good that  he's only gonna be interested in the  wrapping paper to buy the shiniest one  and their plans for the holidays my only  plans to spend some beautiful time with  my son and to eat my own weight in the  lovely Christmas foods you might say  differently after Christmas and then  you'll see post Christmas mean with the  New Year's resolution hopefully  [Music]  you